Cree Homeworld of Hala was touched by
Celestial influence creating a race of
Cree eternals like ardcon and Creed
deviance now the cree lifelong enemies
the skrulls were actually the Deviant
strain from their Homeworld that won out
the cree race plateaued nearly 60 000
years before Earth Humanity matured in
the Creed genome stabilized out of fear
of mutation like what they saw the
scroll as so essentially the cree
stopped evolving and that led the cree
to begin conducting their own Celestial
style experiments one of which resulted
in the Inhumans back on Earth they live
on a secret base on the moon which some
of their eyes could be where old Steve
Rogers is hanging out after all those
Falcon Winter Soldier Clues
foreign
[Music]